merci
[Applaudissements]
je peux plus le supporter alors beaucoup
de stars ont commencé leur carrière dans
les séries a b c et donc c'est pour ça
que vous propose ainsi quà la suite
spéciale à bab des pommes et sitcoms
ok d'accord c'est réfléchi principe est
simple on a regardé le début d'une vidéo
à vous de me donner assez bon on
commence avec une série assez méconnu
c'est elisa un roman-photo
reconnaissaient pas dans laquelle on a
pu voir les talents de comédien de
julien courbet une regardez il ya jugé
sérieux alors est-ce que c'est ce parfum
ne pourrait voir son secret
de séduction
alors à votre avis sept astronautes
devaient être perturbés car julien
combes et va devoir partir
précipitamment pourquoi pour poser un
double vitrage poursuivre un paparazzi
ou échapper à la police paparazzi qui
dit pas paradis ne connais rien mais le
bassin
qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est pour nous
on est plein de sueur toi qui sort les
paparazzi c'est pas vrai ça recommence
attendant leur eau
s'il vous plaît ici
dégonflé la série que j'avais quatre
divorces c'était diffusé en 91 sur l'a50
diffusé en 96 sur tf1 on va regarder un
extrait et regarder ce qui va se passer
ça donnerait juge a vu m roues dont vous
pouvez appeler votre témoin j'appelle
mademoiselle pascal seguin mademoiselle
seguin témoigne en faveur de monsieur
baron c'est magnifique exceptionnel
alors c'est vraiment un truc que sera
sera dans la suite de l'extrait quelle
star de cinéma de cinéma va-t-on voir à
la barre rocco siffredi à la barre bravo
oh là là le g7 ont bâti à la barre non
mathilde seigner batelli mademoiselle
seguin pour en venir directement au fait
entretenez-vous une liaison avec
monsieur bart ou comme le prétend la
partie adverse non la science sont
strictement professionnelle monsieur
baran a été très impressionné par mes
diplômes en marketing il m'a engagé
parce qu'ils avaient envie de donner sa
chance à quelqu'un de jeune
en plus quand monsieur bart on ne
parlait pas de chaussures il me parlait
de sa femme
c'est incroyable elle est mignonne comme
c'est magnifique a complètement oublié
hier parce que j'aurai de majorer
qu'avant les trucs récent son téléphone
n'avait jamais fait série n'ont pas
loupé ça oui monsieur alors je peux dire
à moi je n'aime pas parler de moi mais
juste de seconde j'avais fait le casting
pour premier baiser j'ai pas été pris et
j'avais fait le casting pour cette
émission là quatre divorces et j'ai pas
été pris ma peau que votre cv de 12
heures on n'a pas besoin de savoir
mais voilà merci c'est honnête de sa
part mais c'est pas une casserole pour
mathilde seigner annoncé qu'elle
demandait déjà bien alors des règles
sont maintenant program ab qui
s'appelait pour être libre c'était la
série des to lift la wii ware regarder
les to be free c'est ça une solution
plus problème
ah ouais mais pourquoi tu dis ça la
place m'a proposé les sponsoriser non
dans cette scène nous allons découvrir
une autre star de cinéma
il s'agit de lorànt deutsch qui veut
faire un baby-foot julie gayet qui
drague frank ou bernard montiel en train
de bronzer entièrement nue regardez
c'est de les sponsoriser non oui vous
avez des trucs super d'après laurence
s'il n'y a plus de problème on peut
peut-être car hammami alors
ouais
ton démarrer la vraie oui vous savez que
ça passait tous les soirs sur tf1 ouais
c'était un carton énorme
jean paul bernard hanssens à l'époque on
entend alors justement vous avez joué au
soleil aussi oui bien longtemps en
prison
j'espère qu'on aura des images je pense
qu'on va voir ce soir et j'espère que
non ainsi alors il ya aussi que les
kurdes qui était miti c'était bien sûr
le club dorothée
[Musique]
d'autres disent à cadix est alors tout à
dorothée c'était bien sûr des dessins
animés mythique nicky larson dragon ball
z
dorothée jacky corbier et ariane qui
nous a quittés dernièrement d'ailleurs
ariane disant d'année dix années
d'existence est énorme succès le club
dorothée
est-ce que valérie benaïm sur vous étiez
fan du club dorothée bah oui 90 avait
déjà combattu voiture est évidemment
j'avais 16 ans c'est vrai alors
évidemment j'adorais général je
regardais j'aurais tous les après midi
moi j'adore règle d'or est
particulièrement gênant pardon mais
regardez pas foutu al khor à l'époque
qui était magnifique qu'ils avaient des
tenues comme ça vous était extrêmement
gaulle et pas hésité très très très beau
et voilà j'adorais le jeu de l'avc et je
devrais vraiment beaucoup cette émission
il ya si j'avais une carte de membre au
regard des 712 jeu a toujours mamie
calme-toi un peu stoppé ouais si
regardez à l'eau à la ville
comment peux tu expliquer les règles oui
voilà j'explique pendant que j'ai qui
compose le numéro d'un autre vous si ça
sonne chez vous vous décrochez vous
dites à l'huile et ainsi gagner c'est
pas plus dur commence oui ça y est ça
thomson attend à lui lâché par an
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je prête quand tu vas me pique encore ne
font pas ces genres human mais c'est
presque attention
aulas
[Musique]
on passait
samedi
[Musique]
elhorga
le club nordiste un énorme oui à tel
point qu'elle dormait sur place étaient
tous les jours c'est incroyable une
sacrée bosseuse dorothée elle dorénavant
genre en pleine forme lui si quoi s'est
passé le même délire quoi c'est qui
c'est quoi alors les années 90 pour nous
aussi c'est bien sûr les années bruce
bon les années boys band pouvait pas
passer à côté à partir des années 80 ça
a été une folie en france avec la sortie
et to be free d'egis toile
alliage aussi
[Musique]
ah ah
je suis moi à
écrit comme ça j'ai non ta gueule c'est
à toi qui fais pas maintenant elle fait
pour garder
avec partir un jour si tous les fruits
[Musique]
voici tu soir
le groupe allait bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]